it's a second hey folks welcome to
overdue Doctor Who and I'm gonna do
something that I haven't done in a bit
which is to talk about one of these sort
of supporting shorts that was done now I
kind of dropped off covering these I did
time crash I think I might have done
time of space I can't remember now but I
I eased off doing them because there
started to be a lot more of them around
series 7 and during it most of them
aren't particularly interesting and they
were just pre ludes to what ultimately
you know would just be the episode that
would air shortly after the shorts and
they didn't feel like they were worth
talking about particularly this was
different and I know quite a few people
both the in comments and during live
streams have been asking was I gonna
review this and I think I'd always plan
to but it was it was an experience
rewatching this now I'm gonna explain
what PS is but honestly your best bet
before continuing to watch this is to
just watch it yourself it's four and a
half minutes go watch it come on back
I'll still be here so this was the
additional scene that basically fills in
the gap of Brian Rory's dad and what
happens with him after Amy and Rory are
trapped in New York at the end of Angels
Take Manhattan
so it basically answers what would
otherwise be one of the big hanging
questions hey this character who you
established and we
spent a couple of episodes with at this
point they are seriously impacted by
what's going on and that's not covered
in the episodes proper now what actually
caused this thing to come about at all
and in the form that it does is fairly
interesting so I guess in the process of
getting series seven shot and working on
it
Steven Moffat was talking with Chris
Chibnall and was pretty upfront about
the fact that he felt awful that Brian
was basically a dangling thread and you
know one could argue should this have
been part of Angels Take Manhattan and I
would say it shouldn't because it it
deludes the emphasis on the doctor
companion relationship specifically and
the breaking of that really needs to be
the focus of that episode proper so I
get why Steven Moffat didn't have
anything like this in that episode but
he was talking to Chris Chibnall he said
I feel really bad about that I feel like
such a jerk and Chibnall who had been
the one writing Brian primarily up to
that point because he wrote dinosaurs on
a spaceship and power of three in which
the character appeared he said we'll
look why don't I write an additional
scene because you know we're already
planning on doing all these shorts I'm
working on this pond life thing you know
we could you know shoot that have it be
an extra for like the DVDs or something
and so that was the original plan Chris
Chibnall wrote it because a he volunteer
dude beat basically he'd written the
character more than anybody else and I
put you might have actually been the
only person writing the character
directly up to that point when it came
time to filming unfortunately the actor
who plays Brian wasn't available he was
off shooting something else and the
thing about scheduling is it really is a
pain in the butt especially if you're
know were physically near the other
place where you want to do something I
know in the minds of some viewers it's
like but it was such a short thing he
would have just been a day's work but
yeah but if he's under contract working
somewhere else he
can't leave that to come do this and
they canned the people doing doctor who
can't hold the crew and or scheduled
them for like just to come in for one
day at a later thing they're gone they
want to be set up for longer term stuff
than that so it just becomes impractical
to try and work around that that is why
so many things fall through because of
actor availability so what ended up
happening is this was presented as a
storyboard meaning that for each shot
what would have been the shot of the if
it was done live-action you have a
drawing of the angle and the presumed
positioning and expression of what the
actor was going to bring and they did
bring in Rory to read because they it
has Brian having someone he doesn't know
show up at his door with a note from
Rory and they did bring in Arthur
Darvill to read that because he was
already there because again it was
supposed to be shot at the same time as
pond life so he was around he could do
that so they had him read that so you do
get to hear him deliver that which helps
now I have seen this before it didn't
hit me
nearly as hard when I first watched it
as it did this time I don't remember it
having a massive impact on me at all
actually
now at the time that this aired my my
kid had been born so that had happened I
don't think my grandfather had passed
away yet that would have happened I
think a little after this oh yeah no it
definitely would have been after this so
that hadn't happened yet that's probably
an impact on why this hit me so hard now
and also how relatively recently my own
father made recent
lead to my recording this my own father
passed away I'm not gonna dwell on that
because I didn't have what would be
called the typical relationship with him
but I'm not gonna bog down that but
basically I have I have a lot more
personal experience and a lot more
emotional baggage for this thing to pull
at and get a reaction and it absolutely
did I was in tears through most of this
and I think it does emphasize how
sometimes things being written for a
more mature audience have nothing to do
with violence or sexual content or
language because I do feel like this
scene specifically is written for an
older audience or at least it works best
for an older audience and the reason for
that is it works best if you have enough
relevant personal emotional experiences
that this thing can pull on and really
hit you in the gut because it didn't hit
me as hard before but now I've had more
experiences that feel relevant and feel
referenced by this and so now older more
mature more experienced it hits a lot
harder and that's not to say that it
can't hit you hard at a younger age it
it very some people have varying levels
levels of empathy they're able to to
have at even a younger age some people
actually go through the kinds of
experience I'm going through and
relatively recently at a much younger
age so they've got that they've got
those experiences earlier on but I think
by and large a lot of the stuff is
things that most of us won't have had
experience with until a little later on
in life and there's a wonderful sense of
maturity
to this piece as a result of that so it
is sweet it is very nice that it got put
out out there because it is a delightful
and heartfelt tying up of what would
otherwise be a massive source of like
but-but-but what what about among fan so
it's it's nice that it gets addressed as
sincerely as this and the other thing is
like even though it's not really
animated as I said it's a storyboard so
each image is still and unmoving they
have like some degree of camera shift
like it pans over at zooms in or out but
there's really no movement to it but I
could very sincerely picture Mark
Williams how he would have performed
this how what his face would have done
while reading this and sort of picturing
that my mind maybe I can hit all the
harder because I'm pretty sure he would
have absolutely nailed it I love that it
opens on him watering the plants which
was his justification for her not
traveling someone's got to stay and
water the plants so it opens on the
right action it addresses all the
logistical things you would wanted to
address while being at its core and
emotional peace and I've seen it argued
that this might actually be the best
doctor who think Chibnall has ever
written and I don't know if I agree but
I also would have a hard time arguing
against that this is this is such a
surgical emotional strike well at the
same time at least for me feeling so
sincere and so genuine that it is not
emotionally manipulative the way that
normally something this short would have
to be to get the kind of emotions that
get out of this thing out of something
this short you usually have to be pretty
ham-fisted but this has the advantage of
getting to draw on characters
experiences we already know so it
doesn't it doesn't have to be as
forceful to still land with a very very
effecting blow so if for any reason you
hadn't watched this before or if you
haven't rewash it in a while I would
recommend doing so it's it wears it's
hard on enslavement in the best way and
I'm glad I rewatched it and I had
wondered will I have enough to say about
this thing to even justify a video yeah
turns out I did PS what you think about
it whatever your thoughts are drop
something down in the comments let's
talk about it usual stuff to do like
subscribe comment share this around all
of those are helpful I have a patreon
that's incredibly helpful there's links
to other stuff besides down in the
description but you don't have to click
on any of them because end of the day
you're the council
I'm just running the meetings and until
next time this council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]